bonsoir thomas il ne reste que quelques
jours donc avant cette échéance très
importante pour l'économie américaine
oui du côté du gouvernement américain
les discours sont alarmistes avec cette
catastrophe annoncée pour la date du 18
octobre prochain c'est la date butoir
avant laquelle le plafond de la dette
américaine doit être relevé sinon il ya
des risques de récession c'est en tout
cas ce qu'affirme la secrétaire
américaine au trésor janet et jelen est
là était donc très alarmiste dans un
discours prononcé à la ddte elle que ce
serait catastrophique que les etats unis
soient dans une position où nous
manquons de ressources pour payer les
factures du gouvernement parmi les
conséquences en effet d'un défaut de
paiement de la part des états unis et
bien il y aurait le fait que cela
pourrait entraîner des retraites un non
versés ou encore des militaires non
rémunérés ou même des familles qui ne
toucherait plus les aides de la part de
l'état alors le plafond de la dette des
états unis aujourd'hui est fixé à 28
mille milliards de dollars et d'habitude
c'est plutôt une formalité de relever ce
plafond de la dette qui permet aux états
unis d'investir à crédit ce plafond de
la dette a déjà été relevé près de 80
fois depuis les années 60 mais cette
fois donc il y à une opposition de la
part des républicains au congrès et
c'est pour cette raison que joe biden a
finalement pris la parole et lui aussi à
un discours assez catastrophiste écoutez
le
soyons clair non seulement les
républicains refusent de faire leur
travail mais ils menacent d'utiliser le
pouvoir leur pouvoir pour nous empêcher
de faire notre travail sauver l'économie
d'un événement catastrophique
je pense très honnêtement que c'est
hypocrite dangereux et honteux leur
obstruction et leur irresponsabilité
ne connaissent absolument aucune limite
en particulier au moment où nous
débattons pour sortir de cette pandémie
le locataire de la maison blanche qui
dit ne pas pouvoir garantir à l'heure
actuelle que les états unis ne seront
pas en défaut de paiement d'ici la fin
du mois d'octobre alors si les
républicains bloquent ce vote pour
relever le plafond de la dette c'est
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas distille et
bien donné carte blanche chad joe biden
pour ses différents plans
d'investissement il estime que les
démocrates devraient faire les
manoeuvres eux-mêmes écouter ce qu'en
dit notamment le chef de file des
républicains au sénat
ce gouvernement démocrate unifiée du mal
à gouverner
il n'a même pas pu adopter le projet de
loi bipartite sur les infrastructures
que le président à négocier et le
président de la chambre a promis qu'il
serait adopté la semaine dernière
la majorité doit cesser de sombrer vers
une autre crise évitables les démocrates
doivent s'attaquer au plafond de la
dette
nous leur avons donné une feuille de
route et un préavis de trois mois je
suggère que le collègue se met en
mouvement
vous avez entendu ce parlementaire
républicain pousser les démocrates à
agir eux mêmes parce qu'il existe en
réalité une procédure pour laquelle les
démocrates pourraient en effet parvenir
à relever le plafond de la dette sans
l'aval des républicains mais c'est une
procédure très fastidieuse très longue
et on n'est même pas certain qu'elles
pourraient aboutir avant donc cette
fameuse date butoir du 18 octobre
prochain alors évidemment si les états
unis se retrouvent en défaut de paiement
cela aurait des conséquences terribles
pour l'économie américaine et plus
généralement pour l'économie mondiale
est en réalité elle les républicains
n'ont pas véritablement intérêt à ce que
justement cette situation arrive on
comprend justement dans l'intervention
du parlementaire que vous venez
d'entendre qu'il s'agit aussi et
peut-être surtout d'une manoeuvre
politique de la part du camp républicain
pour semer la division au sein du clan
démocrate on sait qu'il ya aussi des
négociations très difficiles sur les
plan d'infrastructure et les réformes
sociales souhaitée par le camp démocrate
et bien le fait de relever le plafond de
la dette américaine est un autre moyen
de faire pression pour les républicains
évidemment l'enjeu pour eux et c'est
d'affaiblir le camp démocrate en vue
notamment des élections de mi-mandat qui
je vous le rappelle auront lieu au mois
de juin l'année prochaine si beaucoup
thomas abonnés en direct de washington